and thanks for joining us at 6:00 I'm  Kirsten Joyce and I'm Denise fel des we  begin tonight as we often do taking a  look now at the latest kovat 19 numbers  in the u.s. there are over 1.6 million  cases and more than 96 thousand people  have died and over three hundred and  eighty two thousand have recovered  meantime here in our state there are  more than seven thousand cases and 381  deaths  that's statewide Clark County has a bulk  of those with 5700 cases and 320 people  dying so here's a look at where we stand  now in comparison to the World Health  Organization its threshold you can see  Nevada started getting below its  recommendation on May 11th and has gone  down steadily ever since